c'est sur l'île animé d'octobre rouge
que se dresse le nouvel espace
artistique appelée guest deux inaugurés
ce 1er décembre en présence de vladimir
poutine
guest de c'est aussi le nom de
l'ancienne centrale électrique
construite au même endroit entre 1904 et
1908 fermé en 2006 elle est ensuite
vendus en 2015 la fondation d'art
contemporain vais assez dans le but de
devenir un centre artistique et culturel
sur une superficie de 34 mètres carrés
des ce2 abrite en plus de différentes
salles d'exposition une bibliothèque un
cinéma une salle de concert une aire de
jeux un restaurant et un café mais aussi
une résidence destinée à accueillir les
artistes russes et étrangers ainsi que
comme vous pouvez le voir ici les
ateliers de travail du bois de céramique
de textile et de métaux outre sa
composante artistique guest de se
distingue également par son exploitation
des énergies renouvelables ainsi des
panneaux solaires ont été installés sur
le toit du bâtiment
plus les quatre anciennes cheminées de
la centrale électrique aspireront l'air
plus pur présent à 70 mètres d'altitude
réduisant la consommation énergétique
par un système de ventilation naturelle
de parking du musée dispose en plus de
huit bornes de recharge de véhicules
électriques
autre élément naturel 600 boulot ont été
plantés à l'extérieur du musée d'un
système d'irrigation interne collecte et
filtrent l'eau de pluie pour annoncer
l'ouverture prochaine de guest de une
sculpture de l'artiste suisse 11 fischer
a été inaugurée devant le musée au mois
d'août dernier baptisé huit pleines
numéro 4 ce morceau d'argile de 12
mètres de haut a suscité une vague de
mécontentement parmi les moscovites
parmi lesquels beaucoup il voit en
gigantesque tas d'excréments plutôt que
le symbole d'une sculpture en devenir il
a toutefois fort à parier que cette
polémique diminuera en rien l'attrait de
guest 2 dans la majorité des expositions
et des événements seront gratuits
accessibles à 2000 les enfants